Лінія фронту під Бахмутом. Українські військові тут
надійно окопалися. США та інші партнери радили Україні
відступити з міста, кажучи, що ціна занадто висока.
Однак Україна продовжує обороняти Бахмут.
І судячи з усього, готується до великого весняного контрнаступу.
Це буде. Очікуємо. Коли - невідомо.
Ми всі в очікуванні. Цікаво, коли це станеться.
Будемо виїжджати, відпрацьовувати.
Всі, звичайно, чекаємо на цю техніку.
Тому що техніка у нас вже старенька, потягана.
Вона ламається дуже швидко. Чекаємо на щось нове
від наших закордонних партнерів.
Починаючи з травня, українці мали перевагу на своєму боці.
Вони задають темп війни. І, як ми бачили, було три великих
відступи росіян з окупованих територій.
На сьогодні є три фронти: це Крим, Бахмут та запорізький.
Якщо коротко, то в Криму українці досягли невеликих успіхів
за останні кілька тижнів. У Бахмуті росіяни досягли
невеликих успіхів ціною жахливих втрат.
А на півдні, в Запоріжжі, поки великий знак питання,
тому що це найбільш очевидне місце для українського наступу
в 2023 році. Тому обидві сторони нині зміцнюються там
і вичікують, що зробить інша.
Західні військові аналітики сходяться на тому,
що одним із ймовірних напрямків контрнаступу України
є запорізький - з метою відвоювати Мелітополь
і тим самим перерізати сухопутну лінію постачання
російської армії до Криму.
Я вважаю, що бої навколо Бахмута далися дорогою ціною.
Але вони також були необхідними.
Генеральний штаб бачив, що вони можуть зупинити
російські війська в Бахмуті, знекровити їх і змусити їх
використати багато ресурсів, не вводячи власні українські
бронетанкові сили до Бахмута. Це те, що їм знадобиться,
коли вони справді почнуть власний контрнаступ,
який, на мою думку, відбуватиметься на дуже вузькому фронті,
щоб досягти вирішального ефекту, аби зруйнувати сухопутний міст
між Кримом і рештою Росії.
Саме відвоювання Криму, як вважає екскомандувач
армії США у Європі Бен Ходжес, може змінити стратегічну
обстановку на фронті.
Крим - вирішальний терен. Ви можете вбити кожного
російського солдата в радіусі 200 кілометрів від Бахмута,
але це не змінить стратегічну обстановку.
Але якщо ви звільните Крим - це все змінює.
Тому контрнаступ буде спрямований на звільнення Криму,
а потім і решти Донбасу, що, як я думаю, буде пізніше.
Український військовий аналітик Юрій Бутусов
також звертає увагу на важливість Бахмута для ймовірного контрнаступу.
Щодо Бахмута. Втримання Бахмута в таких умовах,
в тактичній обстановці, яка є зараз, має свою логіку у двох випадках:
або якщо зараз в тилу створюється потужна лінія оборони
ефективна, і тоді ми виграємо час для того, щоб потім закріпитися
і не відступати. Або готуються контрудари,
можливо на якихось інших напрямках, можливо на цьому напрямку,
ми не знаємо де. Але сподіваємося, що такі важкі бої в такій обстановці,
яка є зараз, коли ворог глибоко охопив місто з флангів,
коли глибоко просунувся в забудову, що у вищого командування
є своя логіка дій, свій задум, який зараз реалізовується.
Та щоб розпочати будь-який контрнаступ - потрібна зброя і боєприпаси.
В Україну вже прибула частина західних танків,
зокрема британські "Челенджери" та німецькі "Леопарди 2".
А у США пообіцяли передати далекобійні ракети
з керованими боєприпасами GLSDB американсько-шведського виробництва.
Ці "розумні авіабомби", випущені з "Хаймарсів",
мають дальність дії 150 кілометрів, що майже вдвічі більше,
ніж у тих ракет, які нині використовує Україна.
Внаслідок цього під приціл українських військових
потрапило б набагато більше російських цілей,
включно зі складами боєприпасів.
Ви пам'ятаєте, коли "Хаймарси" вперше прибули на поле бою
минулого літа і відразу ж почали вражати російські склади
боєприпасів, російський штаб. І тому росіяни вийшли за межі 90 кілометрів,
яких могли досягати ці ракети.
Отже, якщо Україна фактично отримає бомби наземного базування
малого діаметру з радіусом дії 150 кілометрів, це означає,
що збільшиться кількість російських штабів, артилерійських сховищ
і транспортних мереж, які опиняться у зоні досяжності.
Але поки що українські військові на передовій відчувають
хронічну нестачу боєприпасів для вже наявної техніки.
Тижні два тому відстріляли повністю весь свій боєкомплект
і в нас не було чим стріляти. Чотири дні ми були без роботи.
Тобто "зарядний голод" позначається на всіх.
Нам потрібні снаряди. Готують контрнаступ…
Чим прикривати піхоту? Палками кидати по них, чи що?
Зламану техніку радянської доби тут, на фронті,
доводиться ремонтувати щоденно.
У мене попередня машина була, як швейцарський сир.
Хоча вона і працювала… Оця вся задня частина була повністю
побита осколками. Потім її артилерія так накрила,
що вона вже не вивезла.
Просто залишилася від неї одна рама.
Підтікання мастила або двигуна, або трансмісії -
оце найчастіша проблема. Тріскають патрубки, течуть якісь прокладки…
Трохи вік, трохи такі умови експлуатації досить жорсткі,
що вони постійно їздять, постійно стріляють.
Водночас, за словами військового експерта Юрія Бутусова,
наявність великої кількості західної зброї ще не означає
готовності до контрнаступу.
Нам дали насправді дуже велику кількість зброї.
Ми отримали вже багато сотень західних бойових машин
виробництва НАТО. І треба розуміти, що західні бойові машини
диктують нову тактику застосування.
Тому в сучасній війні важливо не просто навчитися
правильні кнопки і важелі натискати в машині,
щоб вона їхала або стріляла. А потрібне передусім мислення,
усвідомлення сильних сторін цієї бойової техніки
і застосування, планування їх на полі бою.
Водночас Юрій Бутусов поки не бачить передумов
повторити блискучі контрнаступальні успіхи ЗСУ,
як це було восени на Харківщині та Херсонщині.
За його словами, тоді були зовсім інші обставини,
а противник був виснажений і дезорганізований,
що призвело до розвалу оборони росіян.
Що зараз? Ворог має велику щільність військ,
побудував тилову позицію, він зробив висновки.
По всій лінії фронту відриті тилові позиції потужні,
розгорнуті резервні частини, можливо, вони не зовсім боєздатні,
але вони є, вони можуть діяти, це велика кількість людей,
велика кількість техніки. І тому зараз отакий проїзд,
який перетворюється в прорив, він неможливий,
бо тоді були створені умови, а зараз нема.
Бен Ходжес також визнає, що за зиму росіяни мали час
провести роботу над помилками та укріпитися на тих позиціях,
які вони загарбали. Але цей час з користю використали також ЗСУ.
Тому він чекає від української сторони нових несподіваних атак.
Росіяни не дурні. Вони знають, що контрнаступ наближається,
тому намагатимуться цьому якось запобігти.
Очевидно, вони доклали багато зусиль, аби окопатися у траншеях
та розставити різні перешкоди. Але я думаю, що українці виберуть
правильний час і місце, коли погода, прохідність доріг,
всі умови будуть створені, щоб вони могли доставити більше
високоточної зброї великої дальності,
яка допоможе зробити досяжним Кримський півострів.
Атаки на штаби, місця зберігання боєприпасів -
так можна знищити масу. Так ви нейтралізуєте перевагу,
єдину перевагу, яка є у росіян.
Щоб розвалити оборону противника, треба більшу кількість снарядів,
більшу кількість штурмових підрозділів, бронетехніки,
розвідувальних засобів та засобів керування, зауважує Бутусов.
На його думку, головне нині - забезпечити насамперед тактичну перевагу
на фронті, щоб темп втрат противника перевищував
його мобілізаційні можливості.
У війні на виснаження основний фактор переваги,
який створює можливості, в тому числі для звільнення території
- це зниження боєздатності російських військ.
Нам потрібно підірвати їхню боєздатність,
щоб ворог був виснажений, були виснажені його фронтові частини,
виснажені його оперативні резерви, і саме це створює сприятливі
можливості для атакувальних дій, для наступу.
Наступ без підготовки неможливий.
Успішний наступ починається зі створення умов для наступу.
Так от зараз йде боротьба за умови, за ініціативу.
Без цієї боротьби, якщо ми не виграємо боротьбу за ініціативу
- наступу не буде. Тоді, коли це буде, безумовно,
будуть умови для наступу. Зараз поки що говорити про наступ
- це надихати себе оптимізмом.
Тим часом тисячі українських військових вже успішно
пройшли навчання з опанування сучасної західної військової техніки.
Крім того, за інформацією агентства Reuters, Збройні сили України
готують вісім нових штурмових бригад загальною чисельністю
40 тисяч осіб. Це мотивовані добровольці, які прийшли
у військо в рамках кампанії під назвою "Гвардія наступу",
яку запустило міністерство внутрішніх справ України
на початку лютого. Їх планують задіяти
у майбутньому можливому контрнаступі.
Я хочу, щоб війна закінчилася якомога швидше,
і я сподіваюся, що штурмова бригада зробить це
набагато швидше, я хочу бути ефективнішим, тому я її вибрав.
Я перейшов, тому що тут підготовка, ставлення, хороші умови,
багато чого навчать. Ну і щоб швидше поїхати на схід.
Багато втратив друзів там і хочу помститися.
Це реальна можливість дати відпір цій навалі.
Штурмові бригади, а хто як не штурмовики йдуть вперед?
І хочеться себе таким чином реалізувати.
Я прагну тієї, як би то правильно сказати, помсти.
Як би то не було жорстко у 21 столітті, але помста за наших людей,
за тих діток замордованих. Мусимо. Хто, як не ми?
Для Києва багато залежить від контрнаступу,
зазначають західні аналітики. Невдала спроба повернути захоплені Росією
території може послабити оптимізм ключових західних партнерів
України та змусити їх підштовхувати Київ
до переговорів із Москвою.